rosyjski świat 15 przed szkolnymi murzynami
jak ci się podoba ten rosyjski świat
[muzyka]
Mariupol Burlyaev będzie dzisiaj
inny odbiornik lotnictwa żniwnego
artyleria
projekt systemu do siatkówki, który pamięta
wartość mariupolu stała się jej nie stuleciem
Bronię, czy wojownicy zostali mężami tych, którzy zabierają
u barona zamykam całą Ukrainę, spróbuj
za moje doświadczenie odnajdą moje pola na rok
Ukraina
[muzyka]
otrzymaliśmy potwierdzenie dziś rano
z Federacji Rosyjskiej z Ministerstwa
obrona federacji rosyjskiej, która przeszła
od Mariupola do miasta Zaporozhye vora
dnieper jest bezpieczny z takimi znakami
przy wsparciu Czerwonego Krzyża musimy
zmierzali w stronę miasta
Zaporoże niestety
zaczął się moment, w którym byliśmy już gotowi
ostrzał regularnej armii rosyjskiej
federacja wzdłuż korytarza, wzdłuż którego
musieliśmy się ruszyć
mogę polecić i jestem w domu
następna następna ona tam jest, więc przegrywasz
Miałem brody z 14 ramionami i
żony wiedźmy, nie jesteś on, oni go zabrali
jeszcze więcej ich dzieci, naszych rzek, wiedzieliśmy
I
[muzyka]
tu jest podwórko
Szpital położniczy
[muzyka]
dzieci były sumą wszystkich
andra
[muzyka]
łuskanie
nowy dom
[muzyka]